partie de la floride le 5 mars
le costa luminosa a pu accoster à
marseille plusieurs de ses 1400
passagers sont atteintes coronavirus les
voyageurs devront subir des tests de
dépistage avant de pouvoir quitter le
navire
soixante dix sept canadiens sont à bord
ottawa va les aider à rentrer chez eux
le plus rapidement possible la prochaine
escale est une escale en italie
donc il y aurait probablement une autre
fenêtre d'opportunité pour vos canadiens
mais pour l'instant nous sommes tous et
toutes concentrées sur l'option
marseille marie céline bourgault et ses
deux amis devaient quitter le maroc il y
a trois jours
mais comme le pays a fermé ses
frontières elles sont coincés sur place
il ya plus de vols c'est fini pour
l'instant alors la seule solution qui se
présenteraient ce serait bien sûr que
des vols de rapatriement expo planifiée
entre le maroc et le canada
alors si ce qu'on attend c'est ce qu'on
espère le premier ministre trudeau
promet que le gouvernement fédéral
épaulera les canadiens prix à l'étranger
j'ai parlé à aux dirigeants d'air canada
et de wall street hier soir et on a
souligné qu'on va travailler ensemble
pour essayer de rapatrier d'urgence le
plus grand nombre de canadiens possible
en deux jours seulement plus de vingt
mille ressortissants canadiens ont
contacté ottawa pour obtenir de l'aide
afin de rentrer chez eux
le gouvernement fédéral se prépare à la
plus importante opération de
rapatriement de l'histoire du pays
et elle s'annonce complexe et comme un
grand tableau des chèques ou à chaque
fois qu une frontière fermée nero
parfait ferme qu'elle n'est pas rien
faire en effet le bruit des solutions
pour accorder un droit de passage au
canada canadiennes et des canadiens
coincés
il y en a un peu partout dans le monde
ghislaine la forêt et ses comparses ont
tenté de quitter l'inde pour une
troisième fois ce matin sans succès et
finalement
lorsqu'on fait présenter à l'aéroport ce
matin on ne sut que le vol était encore
une fois car series son mari attend
impatiemment son retour au québec
je pensais pas que j'allais m'ennuyer
tension ça me fait juste réaliser
l'importance que ma femme
or dans ma ville et à quel point ma vie
vire à vire
lorsque ma femme n'est pas là ici
olivier bachand radio canada montréal